Aww yeah! Get out your dance shoes, it's time to learn with Taylor Swift's hit song "Shake it Off"
So catchy songs like these ones are an absolutely fantastic resource
for you to improve your English Fluency.
Plus, we will be explaining to you all of the most important native slang and pronunciation.
If you want to be able to understand natives
without getting lost,
without missing the jokes
and without subtitles
then be sure to hit that subscribe button,
and the bell down below so you don't miss a single one
of our new lessons.
Learning English with fast songs like
"Shake it Off" is a lot of fun,
but it can be kind of difficult to understand without a native's help sometimes, right?
That's why we created our free three-part mini course teaching you English with the popular TV series Friends,
so that you can understand your favorite movies,
TV series and even music.
Click up here or down in the description box below to learn more.
If you are a music lover, you definitely want to check out
our playlist with all of our lessons with songs by clicking right up here,
or down in the description box below
Fantastic work today!
Be sure to listen to that song again and again.
And sing along so that you can master all of that new pronunciation and the expressions.
Hit that subscribe button so you don't miss
a single one of our new lessons.
Also check out that free three-part mini course
I told you about.
Check out this other lesson teaching you
with Taylor Swift
And finally check out this other lesson
that I think you'll really enjoy.
Now it's time to go beyond the classroom and live you English.
Aww yeah!